let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to episode
number 14 of let's talk the tony
michaels podcast
there's a lot of stuff in the news of
course
every week we come here to try to
deliver
straightforward raw to buy to the face
commentary
on social and political issues
and thank you for joining me today i
want to bring in sam first because we
were talking about a very interesting
topic
uh before before as we were getting
ready here
and we got on the subject of of
cuss words and social media and there's
a lot of cuss words on social media a
lot
but you were saying sam that that you
have a pinterest board that is a
religious pinterest board
and tell me tell me tell me about this
okay so i've got this pinterest i've got
this
album on my pinterest and it's for like
if i need some inspiration and i need a
little bit of jesus in my life
and i was talking about how like if i'm
at church
and i can feel the holy spirit in my in
my veins
and all i want to do is just be like
[ __ ] yeah
i can't cuss in in church and i don't
know who said i can't cuss
but i can't and that's like my one sin
i guess you could say so you are
you are not just you are not just a
christian you're a
[ __ ] christian i'm a [ __ ]
christian and i wish it was okay to say
that i mean i maybe i'm just not looking
in the right place for the
you're here on you're here on tony
michael's podcast so you get to be a
[ __ ] christian if you want
yeah so so your your dad is a minister
he's been a minister for like
uh uh since he was born yeah right he's
a preacher and
and he's not only a preacher man like
he's got how many theology degrees and
stuff like that
and he's still going second masters in
theology
that is crazy so this is like this is
like
uh dude jesus right yeah so so
when you were a kid you you probably
didn't cuss around it no
no okay but now you do you do customers
once once i hit 18 i was like
dad shit's out of the bag i'm sorry it's
just gonna happen
i'm sorry i'm gonna curse god damn it
but
that's not that that you do not say
which one
okay i don't think i've i've been able
to say it
and like i always feel bad if i did say
it
so i guess that's just the the religious
part
growing up being religious and i just
don't say it
it's because you're taking the lord's
name i'm taking the lord's name in vain
i'm gonna [ __ ] cuz then i'll do it
right
but but gersh so so so do you say gersh
darn it
or they like cat nabbit cat cat nabbit
pat um caught like if you sleep on a cot
i would say caught damn it god damn it
that's it that's
about it so so so the word god as long
as it
is followed up by a dammit or something
like that if i said
gd i'd probably be like [ __ ] why did i
say that
so goddamn uh [ __ ]
son of a so so let me ask you so when
you're in front of your dad
what's the most favorite cuss word in
front of your dad like do you have one
that you're like
this is when we're talking about
something and i say
[ __ ] he thinks that's funny for some
reason well of course poop is funny
yeah and i have caught myself saying
jesus christ
oh okay and i should probably stop doing
that one too what about jesus [ __ ]
christ you definitely
jesus jesus christ [ __ ] now i you
know i i like
so in my tick tocks i use jesus [ __ ]
christ
and i use it when i'm i do the uh when i
do the down shot when i actually hold
the camera down
yeah and it's like i'm talking to myself
my favorite part yeah and i i
i use the word i use the phrase jesus
[ __ ] christ
and what i'm trying to uh what i'm
trying to say there is
is uh what in the what is going on why
you're giving your emphasis that's right
on
the topic jesus [ __ ] like the
stupidity the arrogance
so so i mean that those that is a good
phrase
those three words jesus [ __ ] christ
like if like if
i was gonna choose the two jesus [ __ ]
christ or goddamn it i would definitely
go with jesus [ __ ] christ
if i was gonna take i would too if i was
gonna take the lord's name in vain which
i will
and i do you always do that that is the
one that i would choose yes
so now someone asked the other day on
twitter they asked
what is your superpower and i said my
superpower is the word [ __ ]
and it's the superpower that i had like
i can put [ __ ] anywhere make it work
make it sound
good i can say it in all sorts of
different ways obviously
uh i like the word [ __ ] i mean it's
right there on the screen it's on my
hats
[ __ ] it's right there you know what
and if they don't like the word [ __ ]
them [ __ ] them so so that is like my
favorite
curse word mm-hmm it's probably my
favorite too
i i think a lot of people would say that
that was their actual favorite curse
word as [ __ ]
um now i mean we got a comment here
let's see who's
who's commenting let's see maybe someone
else that's my go-to brandy says that's
her go-to
word as well she knows is the word [ __ ]
exactly now now do you use the word
because a lot of people hate the word
i don't use it often but
if i was really feeling pissy
and i need to call someone something
that's probably the one i would use the
[ __ ] would come out it would come out
so so [ __ ] i mean i like the word [ __ ]
but maybe it's just the way uh my the
way i say
things [ __ ] i don't like how [ __ ]
sounds when i say it so i don't say it
[ __ ] now i probably could
i probably you can't you know really
pirate you look like a boy yeah yeah
well you put the t get the t in there
right
[ __ ] i say dickweed someone's pissing me
off i will call them a dickweed
okay dickweed dickweed now is that
is that like a weed that looks like a
penis or is it
oh i've never tried a visual you just
you just spout this stuff out and never
think about it
i just okay i just say dickweed so but
what you're saying is
well ultimately what we're talking about
here is you're saying
that curse words aren't what defines you
as a christian or non-christian is your
if i had to pick a sin that i couldn't
get rid of
try to pick one i guess it would be
cussing at least i'm not out
you know i don't know
shooting shhh people murdering people
you know all of that and other
other gals husbands or other other guys
wives right you're not you're not
getting adults
because you you have those you know you
have them them them ten commandments you
know those three commandments
that you gotta that you got they should
they have put an eleventh in there for
for me what would the eleventh be don't
[ __ ] cuss
because that would be what i mean isn't
that the i mean everyone
i don't think it doesn't really say
don't cuss doesn't saying anything about
it it doesn't really
my dad the theologist himself never
really
gets on to me so so does does he ever
say curse word now when i say cursors i
mean does he ever like
edge up to a curse word like i've heard
him call
uh people
i don't even know why i'm saying it that
way i've heard him call people the b
word i guess oh yeah like when he gets
really upset he's like
oh [ __ ] is a good word though she's a b
word and i'm like oh calm down down so
so she he says [ __ ] or he says b word
ooh he's done both okay so so
so when he's really mad he'll break out
there full [ __ ]
she's just really feeling something
that's probably the worst word i've ever
heard him say
but if he's feeling it but not really
wanting to say it he just says b word
he okay does he say like
well f word that or something nope i've
never heard him say
so he never refers to the word [ __ ] no
does he say
freaking or frick or fudge
fudge a lot because it's in that
christmas movie oh
fudge well mother fudger yeah i mean
so that's the front door so isn't it but
see what the way i've always looked at
it
is you know everyone wants to have place
a different word
uh uh for uh for a curse word like shut
the front door or what the fudge or
you know fudge you or you know something
like that
fudge
so so so fudge them
so so but everyone wants to place a word
as a place setter for curse words and my
view is is aren't you
but you're cussing i mean because your
intent is
you've got the words so what the [ __ ] is
the difference
why not just [ __ ] say it if you're
gonna work right just say the [ __ ]
word
don't don't put a playsetter in that's a
cop out
i mean most people want to hear the word
now
sometimes though i will agree that there
is some
like comedic relief when you place a a
a a non cuss word in a place of a cuss
word
like uh on the tv show i forget what it
is uh my wife watches it um
it's got ted danza and uh um
she says holy forking shirt
what is that it's the good place
the good place that good place that's
what it's called so so they when they're
in the good place
yeah right they can't they can't say it
yeah right
but she means holy [ __ ] [ __ ] but she
says holy [ __ ] shirt
so but i mean that it again again you're
just
you're just you're saying holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] but you're just changing some
letters around
you you're just changing a little bit of
it right your intent
so so if you if you started a christian
rock band
um do you think you would cuss in the
music do you think you would oh i told
oh i would have so much fun
raise your [ __ ] hands yeah i told you
yeah
jesus [ __ ] christ
[Laughter]
i mean
i bet you could sell 100 million albums
cursing and christian music shoot
holy fork and shirt holy spork and shirt
but i mean i mean
so cussing is is is not
uh it's a universal thing too which is
fantastic but but you get different
different cultures and different areas
of the world that have different words
you know like [ __ ] is a very [ __ ] is
popular in some countries as [ __ ] is
here
yeah right yeah i mean it just depends
on who's saying it but
i guess it depends on you know what
accident crane
ukraine their thing is son of a [ __ ]
like they say son of a [ __ ]
all the time every time son of a
frustrated
son of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] is a very
versatile one and the reason
why is because you can you know it it
can refer to any person
referred to a person you could refer to
the experience you could refer to the
place
the thing a thing you know this car is a
son of a [ __ ]
the trip that we made in this car god it
was awesome
when we went on the trip the person that
we met they were a son of a [ __ ]
no son of a [ __ ] the other nice part
about son of a [ __ ]
is it can be all sorts of forms and
versions it can be
some [ __ ] because sometimes when i'm
writing the word son of a [ __ ] i want
to
someone some [ __ ] s.o.m
song [ __ ] song [ __ ] some [ __ ]
and then batch [ __ ]
you know where you draw it out you know
you really want to put an emphasis on
that dick
so you know this all comes from you know
music though really but music it's
fantastic it's fantastic i love curse
words
i'm going to continue to say them and i
don't give a fudge what the fudge you
think about
about my curse words um
there you go yeah well you know it
happens so i hear you're going to go you
you're not
if everyone knows that sam normally
joins us in the car
she's normally in a waiting line for the
kids but she no longer has to be in a
waiting line now for the kids
so she's free she's at home but she
still has to go pick up another kid here
in a minute i got my boy
so i'm gonna let you go and pick him up
okay and tell him tell him pound tagging
for me and
you know uh don't be cussing in front of
him
don't don't [ __ ] so when my kids cuss
because my kids cuss
and it's obvious why my kids gus because
i cuss exactly but
my my daughter will say the f word and
i'll say
watch your [ __ ] mouth
she's so swell why don't you watch your
[ __ ] who taught you that [ __ ] word
who the [ __ ]
taught you that [ __ ] word watch your
[ __ ] mouth
exactly you know so it happens yeah all
right thanks for joining us
i'm going to talk about some serious
stuff today i was i'm glad we had a
little bit of
comedic relief here about the cuss words
have a good [ __ ]
time and i'm glad that there's
christians out there that are willing to
admit that
not only do they like the cuss they love
the cuss and they think it's appropriate
to cuss while they're worshiping their
god
i jesus [ __ ] christ
all right sammy see you later all right
i'm glad you guys could join us today
there's a lot of stuff to uh
comment on uh politically sorry about
our little diatribe about cussing we
were
we were um we were talking before the
show and
we were talking about cussing so i said
save it we'll talk about this on camera
because you know curse words are good i
like curse words and if you don't like
them
why the [ __ ] are you watching my show
if you do not like cussing and you're
offended by cussing
why the [ __ ] are you tuning into my show
because
we're definitely gonna cuss here and
there's a lot to cuss about today a hell
of a lot to cuss about
um number one matt gatz is still not
under arrest
uh i i'm assuming that we're gonna see
these these charges soon
um but uh i watched a little clip of him
leaving leaving the capitol building as
he was uh voting
uh and he was running down the steps
running away from reporters as he was
running his mouth that's never a good
look
it's this is not going to end well for
this idiot
uh the actual look of this is not gonna
end well
uh some some other news uh the the derek
chavin
char trial is still going on uh the
prosecutors rested their case
and the defense has brought their
witnesses uh they are they are rapid
rapid firing witnesses and of course
these witnesses are
are excusing away the excessive force to
kill george floyd
uh with that derek chovin used on his
the back of his neck
uh to snuff his life out saying yeah of
course
of course of course someone having their
arm in a certain way
uh while they're handcuffed obviously
obviously shows
that he was resisting and and should be
killed with
with with another man's knee and it
should be justified because that person
who saw him turn his arm a certain way
obviously was scared for his life
because this person had his arm a
certain way in the handcuffs i mean
how could you not be terrified of that
so we have that going on but today
with just within the last couple hours
we've had a couple pieces of news
that are not related or not conflatable
but there is something that ties
all this stuff together with uh with the
the use of force now uh when i say use
of force i mean
excessive use of force and deadly use of
force meaning that someone actually dies
at the hand of a police officer
it was reported that kim potter the
police officer that shot
dante wright and brookman center um she
is being charged with second-degree
manslaughter and that means she could
pro possibly face
up to uh ten years in prison than a
twenty thousand dollar fine
um now i uh i i believe it's being
confused whether she's actually been
arrested or not but she is going to be
charged with second-degree manslaughter
that is the reports
that are coming out um now the other
piece of news
that we're seeing also with another use
of force case
is the united states department of
justice is saying they are not going to
file charges against the united states
capitol police officer
who shot and killed ashley babbitt at
the
january sixth insurrection now these two
things are not
conflatable they really are not
comparable they're two different things
but if you look at both of these issues
and you look at people's
opinion on both sides of these things
it's very predictable
so what i mean by that is obviously the
people on the
one side the one side of the issue
on ashley babbitt who are against the
insurrection
uh or are for this police officer
not being charged in the case of kim
potter where uh
she shot and used force against dante
wright
um those same people who are not
for that officer being charged are for
kim potter being
charged more than likely and the same is
true on the other side so if you are
not in favor if you think it's unfair
that kim potter was
is gonna be charged with second-degree
manslaughter for killing
dante wright then you are more than
likely
against or or want the us capital
officer
um charged in the case of the ashley
babbitt being shot and killed
using force now that is the only thing
that ties these things together
is the use of force by a police officer
that that's it the circumstances are
completely different
one was a traffic stop one was a breach
in a secure area
and we can go detail by detail and
compare the videos
because there are videos of both there
are public videos of both these things
happen
both uh and what i mean by that is there
is a public video
that shows actually being shot uh
in her neck as she's breaching the
window
uh and and i don't have the video to
play
and it's easy to find on the internet
you can go search it just search
ashley babbitt video and you'll find
that son of a [ __ ]
but the video clearly shows on the one
side of the secure door
a mob of people trying to breach that
secure door
they're using all sorts of different
objects to breach that secure door
and eventually a window is broken on the
side window of that of that door
structure there there is a door
structure so in other words there's
there's two door flanks on the side with
windows and then there's the actual
double doors
themselves and that is a secure area
and the officers apparently are are are
ordered
to use deadly force if they think deadly
force is necessary
so when there was a mob of people on the
side of that door
beating the door breaking the windows
they finally broke a window
in the one video that you have the one
public video
is of a blogger uh and he yells out he's
yelling because you can see the gun in
the video like you can see it
in the video on the other side of the
glass of the door and he's yelling out
gun gun gun he's got a gun he's got a
gun
now rather ashley babbitt heard him say
that
you know i guess that's debatable but
she did
climb and jump through that window of
the secure door while they were
entering the capitol and they were told
not to breach that door because there
was other officers standing on the other
side of that door telling them not to
breach
now they weren't using force on the
other side of the door
those officers were standing there and
and when she
shot when she shot in the video
you can see the entire crowd changes
their mood
changes their attitude as soon as the
shot fires
boom there's there's an immediate
reaction
and the entire crowd uh on the mob on
the other side of the door beating the
door
stops they kind of look around there's a
swat team that's coming up the stairs
that are right directly in front of that
door
they kind of stop they trying to figure
out what happened
everyone knows what happened the officer
on the other side of the door
that was being breached shot and killed
the person trying to breach the window
um and that officer is now
not being charged by the department of
justice
and there's a lot of people on the right
that are upset about
ashley babbitt the officer that shot her
not being charged now
i guess one could say that maybe maybe
just maybe if the argument is
is to comply and listen to law
enforcement and obey the law
you won't have deadly force used against
you
one would one could surmise that someone
might say that
now we go to another instance
that happened just this week that we get
news that an officer was charged and
there is a video of that use of force
now this is the only thing
this is the only thing that ties these
two events together
is that deadly force was used with a
service weapon
that's it that's the thing that ties
these two
but in our culture in our society and
the social construct that we have there
is so much more that ties this video
together
and that's the conversation that we need
to have and that is
should we have officers using deadly
force
should we when should we when should
they use deadly force
should they be able to use deadly force
and the next question that comes to mind
is
why why are they using deadly force
so when you watch the
dante write video it is a it is a body
cam video as opposed to a blogging cam
video
of the the ashley babbitt so there is a
difference so those are two things are
different
but you see in the video uh apparently
they pulled him over because he had
expired ticket
expired license plates they find out
that he has a warrant for a misdemeanor
um and that justifies to arrest him
on the spot and there he's got his hands
behind his back they are
cuffing him uh what appears to happen is
another officer comes up and
grabs him by the arm uh he moves his arm
away from
whoever is grabbing him at that point it
appears
there is there is a point of either he
falls because he's moving and they're
wretching his arms
or maybe he turns there's body movement
somehow some way something happens
where there's body movement and he kind
of falls into the car
and the driver's seat which they're
arresting him right at the open door of
the car
so if he was gonna fall there really
wasn't anywhere for him to fall but
inside the door near the door um because
the officer grabs him from the opposite
side of the door
when he's turned around well when he
turns around and gets in the door
these officers are terrified they're
terrified they're terrified
absolutely terrified so terrified in
fact
that kim potter yells out taser taser
taser
removes her service weapon
moves her service weapon
and proceeds to tase him with a bullet
now there's been a lot of debate about
this online
about how much training should you have
and
should she know and she had 26 years of
service
now one would imagine that if a person
has 26 years of service and is a field
training officer which means that she
trains she trains other police officers
on how to be
police officers in the field
if she's a trained field trainer
a a a a a field training officer
one would think that she would know not
to
pull her lethal weapon
when she's yelling out for her
non-lethal weapon
and one would think that she would know
when she got that weapon
in her hand that it would be the lethal
one not the non-lethal one
and the other thing is everyone's
pointed out is they're on different
sides of her so she would use a
different hand for each one
and apparently her deadly weapon was on
her predominant
side she's right-handed it was on her
right side
which means her left hand her
non-dominant hand would
pull her non-lethal weapon
but these are the things that tie these
cases together
the other thing that tie these cases
together is the conversation the
national conversation
that we need to have about the excess of
force
and i believe i believe that ken potter
in the moment
was terrified terrified because not only
was she trained to be terrified of a
suspect
who has a misdemeanor and who may or may
not want to be cuffed behind their back
to treat them as if they need to die
especially if they're black
but i think in the heat of the moment
she had such a rush and it was such such
dire dire fear because they've trained
themselves to fear
other human beings in these situations
especially human beings
especially human beings who have a
certain amount of pigmentation in their
skin
to be terrified terrified
because what if he did have a gun in the
car
and that's what he was re who gives a
[ __ ]
this excessive use of force
it's got to be a conversation that we
have it has to be
it has to be a conversation and it's
going to be
we're going to get a verdict in the
murder of george floyd
we're gonna get a verdict
now rather that's guilty not guilty hung
on what charges and what charges they
find him guilty or find him not guilty
we are going to
we're gonna have a we're gonna have a
conversation folks
we're not gonna get around it excessive
use of force
now the thing the thing that ties
the kim potter
use of force to derek chauvin's use of
force on george floyd when he
kneeled on his neck for nearly 10
minutes and killed him
is the fact that she was a training
officer and he was a training officer
what the [ __ ] is going on
so you're telling me you're telling me
that the best of the best of the
trainers
are the ones who are making these
mistakes
because that's how some want to paint it
that oh it's not derek chovin's fault by
god
george floyd was on was on meth he was
on fentanyl he was
gonna die anyways
but the same argument could be made that
oh well he knew he had drugs so he had
to subdue him because
what happens when you have a super
monster with drugs in him he could
kill an officer you have to be afraid
all these cases all of them
have one thing in common
fear fear someone fears someone else
in the ashley babbitt case that officer
on the other side of that door
feared that those people were gonna come
through that door
and when she jumped through that window
he acted on his fear and used deadly
force
now the department of justice is saying
that that force was justified and
they're not going to file charges
against that officer
rather you think ashley babbitt is a
hero or not they are not filing charges
at this point against that officer
that that force has been justified
they're saying it's a justified deadly
force
rather you like it or not now
i i wish ashley babbitt would have
stayed
down where donald trump was speaking
and rallied in protest down there and
didn't breach
breach the secure area in the closed
area of the capital
i wish ashley babbitt would have stayed
on the other side of those barriers
along with all the rest of them
that's what i wish
i also wish when they pulled over dante
wright for
a uh uh
uh uh expired tag and discovered that he
had a misdemeanor warrant for his arrest
that he would have been treated like a
human [ __ ] being and not like some
kind of [ __ ] murderous
person who was going to kill them and it
took 12 officers
and eventually a bullet in his side to
subdue him
and now he's lost
there is no saving him if he was some
sort of hardened criminal which i don't
believe
if he was though will you just [ __ ] that
[Music]
up
and i wish i wish when george floyd when
it was discovered
that george floyd passed what seemed to
be
a fake twenty dollar bill
that those officers would have found out
a little more about that dollar bill
and a little more about the situation
before they decided they were just gonna
put him on the ground and kill him
where the [ __ ] is the humanity anymore
where the [ __ ] is it
where the [ __ ] is it
again we are going to have this
conversation in this country
whether you like it or not this
conversation is going to happen
and and if and if everyone doesn't get
to the table quick
and in a hurry it's going to be a really
rough [ __ ] conversation
and i'm not talking about the people who
are already at the table
there are already people at the table
having the conversation they have been
for [ __ ] decades almost
we had an assault weapons ban from 1994
to 2004.
ever since that assault weapons ban has
been lifted we have
had nothing but a rise in mass shootings
in this country
and nothing but a rise in the gun
culture and the white gun culture in
this country
and it's enough it's [ __ ] enough
enough is enough enough people have died
enough of this [ __ ] authoritarian
machismo
we have to be afraid of you and we're
gonna use our guns to show it [ __ ]
enough
so i will say to all the people out
there
who are second amendment supporters who
are gun owners
who don't want their guns taken away
from them
well you better get to the table and
negotiate
fast you better wake up and you better
start
you better start coming to realize that
you're gonna have to have some
reasonable arguments here because if you
don't
we're gonna have the conversation
without you it's gonna happen
and you're not gonna like it and really
no one's gonna like the outcome here
if we have to have this conversation
without the entire country having it
no one's gonna like it it's not gonna be
fun folks
it won't be it will not
be fun
because this use of force this deadly
use of force
and this and this gun culture and white
privilege and white grievance and all
this [ __ ] is tied together
rather you like it or not
the reason why people are pissed off
that that officer at the united states
capital is not being charged
because ashley babbitt breached a secure
area and he used deadly force which
the department of justice is dean
justified is because she's
white how the [ __ ] was he supposed to
know she didn't have a gun
if your argument is that kim potter
should have shot and killed dante
wright because he may have had a gun in
that car why the [ __ ] shouldn't that
officer shoot ashley babbitt then
who the [ __ ] knows if she was carrying a
weapon
enough is enough of this [ __ ]
it's time to have this conversation and
again it is not gonna be easy
it's gonna be a really rough one folks
[Music]
especially under certain circumstances
it's gonna be a rough one
but to all you [ __ ] gun nuts out
there who believe that you're gonna use
your guns to force
everyone else and into letting you own
guns
you are making it worse for yourselves
you are making the argument and the
negotiation worse for yourself
that's what you're doing you're making
it worse your argument
is being thrown in the trash
so if you want to be part of the
conversation if you want to be part of
the negotiation
if you want if you want your voice to be
heard
you better get off your ass stop your
bullshitting
and come to the [ __ ] table because
there are people who are willing to
negotiate
and to do something about this
there are
rightfully or wrongfully it's called the
the party that's willing to do something
is called the democratic party
the republican party is completely
willing completely willing to pander to
the nra and these in the gun lobby
joe biden signed executive orders
that didn't move the middle needle that
much
and people weren't mad because everyone
looked at everything they did and that
he that he signed for and he was
they're like yeah that makes sense
yeah that makes sense
[Music]
and if you're if you're in that if you
are in
if you are in that
that position
where you're saying yeah that makes
sense even though i'm
voting republican that makes sense
you are the problem
you are you're voting for people who
aren't doing what you want them to do
which is causing the division in the
first place
everyone thinks there's a huge race
divide in this country there is not a
huge race divide
there are plenty plenty plenty of white
people out there
that that view people of color as human
[ __ ] beings
plenty of them that are willing to stand
with them and be their [ __ ] allies
here
and we've had enough of this [ __ ] enough
of your [ __ ] white privilege [ __ ]
we've had enough of it
enough is enough it's just enough of it
and we know we know the game here we
know the stakes we know what you're
trying to do
you're trying to hang on to it as long
as you can because
oppression to the oppressors
excuse me equality to the oppressors
feels like oppression
there's nothing being taken from you
nothing
not a goddamn thing
not your guns not your privilege
nothing is being taken from you stop it
stop believing facebook
stop believing that lying sack of [ __ ]
donald trump
nothing is being taken from you frankly
we're gonna open there's gonna be a
whole new world
that opens up to you a whole new world
with all new opportunities
if you just [ __ ] open your closed-ass
eyes
stop believing the [ __ ]
stop it
the sooner we get to a place where
we can get what we consider uneducated
people because these are not uneducated
people
folks these are not uneducated people
everyone everyone wants to just put
these people in the stupid basket
and unfortunately sometimes i put them
in the stupid basket
they just you just want to throw them in
the stupid basket these are not dumb
people
they aren't they are intentionally doing
this
they are intentionally doing this
they know they know that the use of
force at the capitol on ashley babbitt
was more than likely justified they know
that
she was breaching a secure door
but she was doing it in cause for donald
trump so they can look the other way
just like donald trump is a skeezy [ __ ]
grabber
and any other person in the world that
wasn't donald trump that was a skeezy
[ __ ] grabber they might have a problem
with
but because he panders to white
supremacists it's okay
he spreads our message and as long as
you spread our message it's okay
you [ __ ] better get to the
table and start negotiating
because we're gonna have this
conversation nationally really [ __ ]
quick and really [ __ ] soon
really quick and really soon
i believe that whatever the outcome of
this trial
of of this cop and murdered george floyd
we watched him do it we watched him
and no matter what you say no matter
what you say about drugs in his system
and george lloyd's system or that he was
scared
whatever the [ __ ] you want to say none
of that evidence shows up in any of
those videos
none of that evidence none of that
evidence shows up in any
any of the medical studies of the bi
the autopsies it actually says the
opposite
just because george floyd had drugs in
his system
and just because george floyd
was probably a drug addict does not
warrant the death sentence
and it does not warrant a police officer
to be judge
jury and executioner on the street
because he was frightened that the crowd
was a little riled up that he was
killing george floyd
the same way the same way is being
pulled over for
look if i was pulled over with my skin
color for an expired tag and i had a
misdemeanor warrant
i wouldn't be shot and killed
i wouldn't even fear it
even if i got pulled over in a vehicle
that i knew had expired tags
wouldn't even run through my mind to
call my
mom to tell her i was being pulled over
even if i knew i had a warrant for a
misdemeanor
no way would i worry if i was gonna lose
my
life
dante wright
should have feared for his life because
those officers saw his skin
and they feared for theirs
just like we seen the lieutenant out in
virginia they got pulled over in a gas
station he pulled over in a lit
area and they immediately immediately
drew their weapons on him
immediately he was even clearly trying
to de-escalate the situation
and those officers did nothing but
intentionally escalated
they intentionally escalated it
maybe maybe
maybe that's the difference between the
use of force
on dante wright george floyd
and even the lieutenant in virginia
than ashley babbitt because the officers
on the side of the door that she was
trying to breach
were trying to de-escalate the situation
they were calm they were cool they were
collected on the other side of the door
they were trying to de-escalate the
situation
it didn't work there was a mob of people
it's difficult to de-escalate a mob of
people i will hand them that
now i think they were
the reason why they were trying to
de-escalate as a as opposed to use
forces
because of the color of those people
skin that we're breaching that door
100 full stop
you can say what you want you can say
what you will
but there's a hell of a lot to white
privilege when you're approached by the
by law enforcement a hell of a lot
a hell of a lot and us white people
don't notice it because we're afforded
that privilege without even knowing it
if a white dude was pulled over for an
expired tag and had a misdemeanor
warrant out for his rest
my guess is he would have walked away
from that in a pair of handcuffs rather
he resisted or ran or drove away or not
no way no shape no form would a weapon
been drawn to shoot and kill somebody
accidentally or on purpose no way
and if it was if it was done there would
be
more outrage than you could even [ __ ]
imagine
about that officer shooting and killing
a white guy
for pulling him over with expired tags
but dante wright has a little more
pigmentation in his skin
so they feared him
he should fear them
this conversation's coming folks it's
coming quick fasting in a hurry
this trial is is gonna force us to have
this conversation
we're gonna have it
get ready arm yourself with the right
argument
because they're they're going they're
going to pull out all stops here
they're going to pull out all stops
every last [ __ ] argument that they
have drudged up for the last 50 years
about use of force they're going they're
going to use them
and it's all it's all going to become
it's all going to come from this q anon
white supremacist
right wing [ __ ] every last [ __ ]
bit of it
and the saddest nastiest grossest part
about it
is the evangelical christian community
has bought it hook
line sinker full stop because what would
jesus do
in the case of dante wright what would
jesus
do what would he do in the case of dante
wright
i could only imagine i can only imagine
what jesus would do
to dante wright because he had an
expired tag and had a misdemeanor
warrant
i could imagine that they probably would
have used force to handcuff him
and then when he when he when he seemed
to be resisting to get into the pair of
handcuffs
to to confuse his taser with his sidearm
and shoot and kill him
i would imagine that's what jesus would
do
[Music]
well i didn't expect to be able to be at
50 minutes after that conversation but
here we are
i've rambled on and on and on it's been
a good episode for episode 14. i
appreciate you
joining me this afternoon come back next
week on wednesday at three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern and join me
for the podcast now if you missed it
live today don't worry you can go to
youtube you can find it there we're on
apple podcast now so everyone out there
that uses
apple podcast we're on there so you can
get the audio but if you want the visual
if you want the video then join me on
youtube
also we're streaming on twitter i'm on
twitter
follow me on twitter you can follow me
all these places at the tonymichaels.com
all right d tony michaels but you can go
to thetonymichaels.com and you can find
all those
little things you can go to the tweet
tweet you can go to the tick tock you
can go to the youtube channel
it's all there folks and i'll post the
link to this episode on
on thetonymichaels.com but it'll also be
on the twitter feed
and you guys know i like to cut clips of
the show and put them up so everyone can
see them
but subscribe to the youtube channel
here follow me
on tick tock follow me on twitter
and really you know i'm sure there'll be
plenty of
[ __ ] to talk about next week because as
they're moving through this trial
they're moving very quickly
and it seems like the events of the the
uh dante wright being shot by kim potter
it seems like those events are moving
pretty quickly so i'll
i'm sure we'll have some news on some of
those events next week
and hopefully next week i can
talk about the perp walk of matt getz i
am
so excited to talk about the perp walk
of matt yeah we got a preview of it
today i talked about it earlier
we got a preview of it him walking down
the steps and did you notice he had his
mask on
it's almost like he was trying to hide
his face
he doesn't believe coronavirus is real
but he's wearing a mask outside
and running down the steps trying to
trying to get away from the press in his
car as fast as he [ __ ] can while he's
running his mouth
and that is not a good sign that is only
that is only an indication of
of a perp walk to come people a perp
walk to come so
until next time until next week [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them them